ضيف انت اليوم هي قليله الاطلالات ولكن
عندما نتحدث عن نجمات مصر هي دائما على
راس القائمه ضيفه اليوم هي الممثله
المصريه العربيه نيللي كريم اللي راح تكون
وياي في هذا اللقاء قصير في لوس انجلوس
هل تطمحين الى العالميه تسوين عمل عالمي
ولكن انت مكتشف الوطن العربي
هي ما بتبقاش كده هو دائما الواحد بيستنى
العمل
المناسب او يبقى عمل يضيف له لكن مش مجرد
يطلع يعمل اي عمل بره فاهم اا لما يبقى في
موضوع حلو يبقى موضوع انترناشونال ان سبرت
مهرجانات كثير يعني رحت مهرجان كان
ومهرجان فانوس وكنت في لجنه التحكيم في
مهرجان فارس همم
على فكره ممكن تطلع من بلدك للعالميه برده
يعني همم ده شيء وارد بس مع فيلم كويس مع
موضوع مهم موضوع الانترنت
هو وحشه جدا فبيعمل كل حاجه في سبيل ان هو
ينقذ ابنه على رمضان القادم مش هنا
المرتقى من اللي كريم
اول مره يمكن اعمل الصعيدي لان اللغه
الصعيديه همم لغه همم
حلوه جدا ولكن صعبه صعبه في نفس الوقت
طبعا هشام موجود خلف الكاميرا حضر نفسك
لازم تشاركني بعد شويه
خبرني اكثر عن نيللي بالمنزل هل هي سبات
تطبخ لك ولا ولا شنو الوضع
حاجه يعني
اساسي
والله حاجه جميله يا طيبه
جدا دمه خفيف يعني حاجه طبعا
الانجليزي والكاتب انجليزي هيطلع شكل
مختلف جدا متصور بطريقه مختلفه همم
ان شاء الله صعيدي باذن الله في رمضان
هل ممكن نشوفكم بعمل مشترك انتم الاثنين
وقت مناسب وكل حاجه بيبقى ليها الموضوع
يعني انا دائما بادور على
همم انا يعني في ناس مثلا بتدوار على طول
انا بادور على الموضوع كله على بعض
وبيتكلم عن ايه همم
هيدف لي هل انا هاضيف له ف- فدي حاجات
مهمه قوي همم والله انا يعني في كم مشروع
همم انا وهشام معرضين علينا بس احنا
ماجلين لهم شويه
عامل حاجات كثيره جدا جدا جدا فاهم مش
هتعمل حاجه دلوقت وبالذات يعني ده قرار
يعني الفتره اللي فاتت اخذناها مش هنعمل
حاجه غير لما يكون خلاص بقى حاجه هتضيف
حاجه على نفسها تعملها حاجه نفسها تطلع
فيها فلو الموضوع مضبوط حلو وحاجه هي
شايفاها جديده